In this game dev course you will learn how to
create an endless runner game using Unreal Engine
and c++ file Fahir teaches this course. He has
created a ton of game development tutorials and
he is an excellent teacher. What is up guys Fahir
here and back out again with another Unreal Engine
tutorial this time a c++ one Yes, because a lot
of your doozy blows blows. Okay, I'm going to
do a c++ tutorial. Anyways, let us take a look at
the game that we are going to create. So over here
I have my editor if I hit the play button, it's
a simple side scroller game. So if I, you know,
jump and all that stuff, you see, we can jump
we can move, the goal is to avoid this wall that
is chasing us because if it touches us, we are
going to die. And of course, we are going to have
obstacles along the ways such as these platforms,
such as the spikes that we are hopefully going to
see pretty soon, because they're not spawning all
of this time. There we go, we have the spikes. If
we touch the spikes, bam, we are dead, the level
is going to restart. If the wall hits us, bam, we
are that the level is going to restart. As you can
see, it looks like a basic game. But we are going
to learn a lot of cool things, especially c++
wise, because we're going to do all of this in c++
from scratch coding everything and you're going
to see me code and you know, you're going to enjoy
that and learn a lot and yada yada yada. Anyways,
what else can I say? Let's jump into this.
Course. Yeah, it's a mini course. What else
is there? No, it's a mini course. Okay,
it's tutorial mini course, whatever, let
us jump into it and create the school game.
Alrighty, then my game devolves. Now that we
saw the game that we are going to create, let us
create the game. So over here, I have the Unreal
Engine Project Browser, we are going to click here
on games. And by the way, this is unreal engine
version four point 25. And we are going to select
our third person project. So not the blank one,
but the third person because we need some elements
from that, you know, third person package.
And over here, we're going to click on Next.
And from blueprint, I'm going to click on the
drop down list and select c++ because Yay,
this is a c++ course. And over here, I'm going to
name my project I'm going to call it side rather
CPP. Of course, you can think of something more
creative than that, I'm going to click here Create
Project and wait until the project is created.
And then I'm going to come back. And here we are
finally. So now what we are going to do is we are
going to create the player and specifically the
player class over here, by the way, I have this
engine content, we will use that as well. If you
don't have it, you're going to click here where it
says View Options. So this right here that I draw,
so click on that, and from there, you're going
to click this checkbox show engine content. So
make sure that that is checked. And then you will
be able to see what I see in my project. Also one
neat trick, if you find that all of these elements
inside of the editor are too small, especially if
you have a big monitor, you can go over here on
the under window and then developer tools. And
then you can go over here widget or reflector.
And let me just bring that bad boy over here.
And this is the scale for the application. Usually
I set it at 1.16 and it is going to rescale my
application basically make it a little bit larger
and that stuff so that I can see more better.
That's all there is to it. Anyways, going over
here in the content, I'm going to right click
and create a new folder that I am going to call
maps because over here we're going to create a new
map and that is going to happen under File and the
new level basically new level I said map but as
the same thing Ctrl S to save it I'm going to save
it over here and I am going to call this one game
play and there you go. So the first thing that
I'm going to do with this gameplay is I'm going to
remove the floor that we have over here so simply
delete it and there you go. And next I'm going to
go here into geometry and meshes and I'm going to
take this template for and please head over here
and there you go. Let me just position this bad
boy so for the x is going to be zero for the Y
is going to be zero z is going to be 20 and I am
also going to rescale it so I'm going to click
here on this lock icon to lock the scale and I'm
going to say point 25 and there you go. rescale it
and Wallah. Also in regard to the player start
position let me just click on that yeah, it is
going to be where it is. And this is where we are
going to spawn our player. Now before we proceed
to create the player class over here inside of the
project settings and in the input we are going to
have some mappings and axes. So basically we
only need the jumps I'm going to delete this
reset we are simply click here on this x and
delete it. Here we are going to have move right
we're not going to have move forward and all of
these stuff. So look up look rate, turn, turn
rate and move forward. We're going to delete all
of these and leave only all of these. Of course
you can also filter these so we Don't need the
GamePad, I basically only need the spacebar. But
again, that is up to you, depending on if you want
to create, maybe you want to practice or whatnot,
I don't know I'm not you I'm not, you know,
I'm not controlling you and stuff like that.
So there you go. So we should have jump and move
right for the job, we have the spacebar for the
move, right A and D, you can also add the, you can
also add the left and right that is totally up to
you, I am not going to go in there, you know, do
not judge me. So now we can go over here inside of
our c++ or c++ classes. And from there, there you
go. Here we have our side runner CPP character,
I am not going to use that one I'm simply going to
right click and go here New c++ class, it is going
to inherit from the character I'm going to click
on Next. And I am going to call this one runner
character and hit the Create class. Of course, you
know that it takes a while for Unreal Engine to
you know, compile and load all of this, I am going
to get an m two SSD just because of this, like I'm
not getting just because of this, I'm getting
an es m two excuse me SSD that can read for I
believe, three 3500 megabytes per second. So that
is what I'm getting. Okay, this is what I'm going
to get. And finally here is my class. So we have
the runner dot h file and the runner dot cpp file.
If you don't know the difference between the two
I'm quickly going to explain so in the dot h file,
we declare everything that we need and
inside of our dot cpp file we then code
all of that that we have declared simple.
Yes, it is. So what do we need over here,
right below where it says our generated body, I am
going to declare a u property. So it's prah per T,
there you go. Sometimes I cannot spell and I'm
going to call it the visible anywhere, there you
go. And this one is going to be our class. This is
called a forward declaration when you type a class
so that we don't have to include the file over
here. And I'm going to say you camera component,
and it's a pointer. So we need to denote that with
the star. And I'm going to call this one side view
camera. Now as I said, this is called a forward or
forward declaration, I believe I'm not 100% sure,
because I'm not good with those names, I don't
care. But essentially what is the point of this
is that we declare it with a class over here so
that we don't have to use the include over here,
you see, because every single thing that we use,
for example, if we want to use functions from the
character, we need to include the game framework
character. But I don't want to do that for the
camera component because every time you include
the runner dot h file anywhere in your class or in
any other class that is, then it will include all
the includes that come with it, but when you use
it like this, then it will not include them. But
inside of here runner.or runner character dot cpp
then we are going to include it and that is the
better way to go. So over here, this is you know,
the constructor for our character at the Begin
Play and all of the good stuff tick and set up
player input components, so we're not going to
touch any of those. Instead, what I'm going to
do is over here protected. And over here I'm
going to declare my own functions and variables.
First things first, I am going to declare here
void move right and this one is going to take
a float value as a parameter. And of course in a
moment of do it is going to start complaining with
a green line below this move right because
we then declare it inside of the dot cpp
file. Don't worry about that we will do it in
a few moments. So over here, we're also going
to create a public and this one is going to
return our you camera component and again,
it is a pointer and I'm going to call this one
get side view. So get side view camera component.
And this one is going to take a constant or
actually it's a constant and it is going to return
the side view cameras Simple as that. Next we are
going to have another public function that I'm
going to call void re start level this is going
to happen at the end when our player gets killed,
which is something that we saw as well.
Also what I'm going to create and this
is what I said is going to complain with this
Don't worry we will implement this in a view.
Over here I'm going to create a u function.
And this one is going to be our void on
over lap begin, it's going to take a u primitive.
So prayer may tiv component which is a pointer and
I'm going to call this one over lapped component,
comma. It also takes an A actor Simply an actor,
but it's spelled a actor. It's a pointer
and I'm going to call this one other actor.
There you go, we're also going to take another
primitive component. So I'm going to copy this
here and paste it and it's a pointer. So again,
we need to use this star over here. And other
comp or other component, this I'm going to
call it to takes an int 32. Other body index,
a Boolean B from sweep. And last but not least,
a constant of F hit result. And over here sweep
result, there you go. And last but not
least, a few more private variables,
one is going to be the Z position. So float z, the
position, there you go, it's position like that,
we are also going to take an F vector, which is
going to be our temporary position that I'm going
to denote is equal to f vector like that. And last
but not least a Boolean to denote if we can move
or if we cannot move. Now of course over here, as
you can see, it is complaining for the move right
and the restart level, it is not complaining
for the on overlap again, but it will start
complaining because I'm still waiting for that
SSD to come. So what we need to do is we need
to declare this function over here inside of our
runner character dot cpp file. So we need to, as I
said, declare it and that can happen by going over
here and declaring and typing yet you know, void
a runner character call on call on and so on, and
so forth. But there is a quicker way to do this,
what we can do is we can click on this move
right then I can right click, and then I can
go here quick actions and refactoring. And over
here I can say create declaration definition.
And there you go. When I click on that, it is
going to create it of course, you know, this HDD
drive, it's driving me nuts. And I will probably
have to cut out this video because you know, if I
sing to you, that will cost you extra. I mean,
this is on YouTube, you don't pay anything for
this. But there you go, finally, okay, so now if
I go here in the runner, there we go. So we have
the void runner move, right, we can do the same
thing for this over here. So we can, you know,
do the same thing for the restart level by typing
void a runner character call on call on will ride.
But instead of that, I'm simply going to right
click again, quick actions and refactoring. And
I'm going to create a definition for it. And
last but not least, we need to do that for
on overlap begin. So quick actions refactoring
create declaration, there you go, save this over
here, save this over here, and voila, here are the
functions that we need. So from here There you go.
So what are we going to do when it comes to our
runner character? Well for our runner character
here is where I said that we are going to add
those includes. So first one I'm going to include,
and that one's going to be components There you
go, it's come ponents and then backslash and this
one is going to be capsule component dot age, and
I'm going to include everything that we are going
to use so over here we're also going to include in
quotes, game frame work, and then backslash spring
actually we don't need the spring our component we
need the camera so I got carried away usually when
use the camera use the spring arm but I'm simply
going to use the camera without it. So camera dash
or backslash camera component dot h There you go.
And also include and over here game frame work. So
game frame work, actually, yeah, it's Capital
Framework like that. And backslash character,
movement component. And there you go, actually
thought Ah, and now there you go. So this is the
or these are the includes that I was talking about
when I forward declared the camera component. So
instead of using this camera component include
over here, I'm simply going to forward declare
it like this. And then over here I'm going to
use the include because if we need to use the
runner character in some other class and we need
to include the runner character dot h file, when
we include that, it will not include this import
because this import is inside of the dot cpp file.
So over here inside of our runner character, which
is the constructor basically, what we are going to
do first we're going to set the capital component
so I'm going to say get capsule component.
And from there, I'm going to say in it
capsule size and the size is going to be 42
On the X and 96, on the Y, there you
go. I'm also going to set the channel to
response to collision with overlap, basically
setting the collision settings to response
with overlap. So over here, I'm going to say
get capsule components or get the capsule,
capsule component, there you go. And over
here, I'm going to say set collision response
to channel. And from here, going down, I'm
going to say ECC underscore game trays channel,
and is going to be traced channel one. And
I'm going to say a CR, over lap, there you go.
And moving forward, we are going to the note
that we are not going to allow the controller
to rotate us, instead we are going to use
our own or basically we're going to control
this class from within itself. So I'm going
to say here be use control rotation pitch,
that is going to be equal to false. I'm also
going to simply copy this and paste it, paste,
paste it and this one is going to be pitched then
we're going to have the role. And last but not
least, we're going to have the yard basically, as
I said, this is not going to allow the controller
to rotate, the controller is not going to rotate
this character instead, we are going to do that
from within this class. And since this is a side
scroller, we're not going to rotate at all. Next,
I'm going to create the camera so our side
view camera is going to be equal to create
default sub object and it's going to be type of
view camera component like that. And I'm going to
give it a name by passing here a text. And that
name is going to be side view camera Simple as
that There you go. Nothing complicated, I'm also
going to or I don't want the controller to rotate
the camera as well. So I'm going to say side view
camera. And over here, I'm going to say be use pan
control rotation that is going to be false.
So this is not going to allow the controller
to rotate the camera. Next, I'm going to set the
character movement to face the direction that we
are moving to so we are moving to the or in
this case, because the game is a side scroller,
we can move forward or we can move backwards.
So that is why I'm going to say over here,
get character movement. And from there, I'm
going to say be orient rotation. So orient
rotation to movement that is going to be equal
to true, which is basically going to allow us
as I said, to rotate towards the direction where
we are going. Now this is going to be the rotation
rates, I'm going to say get character movement,
but I'm going to copy it because we're going to
use it the few times over here. And I'm going to
see here a rotation rate. And that's going to be
equal to App rotate or, and over here I'm going
to say zero for the X 720 for the y and 0.0 F
for the Z now if somebody is confused if this is
your first time seeing Unreal Engine c++ code,
first things first, I'm advising you to go
through my c++ tutorial series here on YouTube.
You'll have that in my Academy as well. But what
I wanted to say is if you're confused why I'm
using here is 0.0. But over here 720 point and
I don't add zero what is the difference? Well,
there is you there isn't actually so you can
add zero you can emit zero is the same exact
thing. So that is when it comes to the rotation
rate that I'm going to actually point zero here
and move this backwards, and there you go. So
next we're going to set the gravity scale for
our characters. So I'm going to say gravity
scale that is going to be equal to two.
I'm also going to set the air control so air
control is going to be equal to zero point f
air control is basically how or the how much
control of our character do we have while he's
in the air the higher the number, the higher
the control. Next we're also going to say here,
our jump z velocity is going to be equal to 1000.
That's basically going to be you know how far or
how high we can jump. Next over here I'm going to
say ground reaction is going to be equal to three.
And ground friction is basically you know
the collision with the player and the ground.
Also over here I'm going to set the max
walk speed that is going to be equal to 600.
And last but not least max fly speed that is
going to be equal to also 600. And there you go.
And now we are going to get our temporary
positions and we'd say temp pose that is
going to be equal to get actor location, which is
the current location of our actor or Basically the
game character and I need this temporary position
because I'm going to say our z position variable
is going to be equal to temp, position
that z plus 300.0. There you go.
And now what do we are, what do
we need to do, we need to bind,
we need to bind our controls if we want to move
the character. So over here, we have our set up
player input. And this is where we are going to
bind the axes and the jumping and all of the good
stuff. So now we have this player input component
that is passed over here in the setup input
component. So I can simply use that. And I can
say, player input component, which is, you know,
called as you can see, to bind functionality
to input. So I'm going to say over here, bind
action. So bind action, and I'm going to bind
the jump action and how where or what, where do
I have this jump action? Well, the jump actions
over here, if I go into the project, here it is
action mappings. And this is the jump action.
So this name needs to match up with the name
over here that we specify. So bind that to. And
of course, because this is an action, we can press
it and release it. So I'm going to say IE pressed
basically, what do we want to do when we press the
jump button? Well, over here, we're going to bind
it passing this as well. And over here a character
call on call on jump, there we go. So
essentially, when we press the jump button,
or in our case, the jump button is denoted with
the spacebar. So when we press the spacebar,
we are going to call the jump functionality from
the character that we have inherited. Because this
class inherits from the character see here public
a character. And the character has some built in
functionality such as jumping. So I'm also going
to copy this because when we release it, we are
going to so this is I II pressed and over here,
ie released. So when we release the jump button,
instead of jumping, we're going to stop jumping,
this will stop the jumping of the player and he
will start to fall down Simple as that. Next I'm
going to take the player input component, and
now I'm going to bind the axes instead of binding
the action and I'm going to bind the move right.
And I'm going to bind it to this referring to this
class and referring to the a runner character call
on call on move right? There we go. So this
right here is going to bind to the move right,
which is again, going back over here, this is that
move right, it is going to bind to our move write
function, which is this function over here. So
essentially Now, over here in our move right,
we are going to add the code that is going to
move the player. So over here, we're going to test
if can move and we are going to use this to
the note if the player can move when he's dead,
we will see that later on. But if the player can
move we're going to say add movement input. And
from here I'm going to say f vector. So it's f
vector, and over here, zero movement on the X on
the Y is going to be one and on the Y or actually
on the Z, it's also going to be zero in over here,
I'm going to pass the value that we have. Now in
order for this to work we do need to denote inside
of our Begin Play that can move. So can move is
going to be equal to true. This is when we start
our game, which is you know normal and all of the
good stuff, otherwise it will not work. So I'm
going to hold Ctrl Shift and press B This is going
to compile my code. And of course, we're going to
wait a few moments. I don't know maybe I will cut
out this video depending on how much it will take.
Because again, my SSD is the lot here, I can also
try to sync to you none and then and then and
then there you go. It worked. You see here build
succeeded, which means now we can go inside of our
editor. And if I were to go into the gameplay and
hit the play button, we do see a character and we
can move the character but this is not the her
character. This is the built in one that we have
that we have created with the project. So in order
to create our own character, I'm going to right
click over here and go into the new folder. I'm
going to call do some blueprints. And from here
I'm going to click and go inside of that folder
and I'm going to create a blueprint class and
I'm going to inherit from the runner character.
So here is my runner character and I'm going to
click on that one and I'm going to say BB runner
character. So this is now our character. This is
going to create our character from the class that
we have just created. Of course, as you can see,
we don't have anything. We do have the side view
camera you see we have created it over here, but
what we need to do is we need to click on the mesh
and over here, we need To add the Skeletal Mesh,
which is basically going to be our mannequin,
which is this bad boy over here, I'm also going to
set his z location to negative 97 to lower him a
little bit down as you can see, and I'm going to
rotate him 90 or minus 90 degrees like that. And
basically that would be it. I can compile save
this well one more thing we do need to attach
here, a blueprint class for his animation,
which again, click on the drop down list and we
have the third person an MVP, which automatically
will make him or he will be animated. Now in order
for us to add our character right now in the game,
we need to create our own game mode because
if you remember from the previous tutorial,
previous Unreal Engine tutorial series, over here,
inside of the maps and modes, you see we need to
create our own game mode. Because currently,
again, if I hit the play button, this is not our
character. See, this is not the character that we
want. Instead, over here, I'm going to right click
and blueprint class, and I'm going to filter from
game mode or filter for game mode and click here
and inherit from game mode is going to be our
BP runner or side runners cuse me side runner
underscore game mode. And let's go over here
into the into the Project Settings and select the
BP side runner game mode. And here instead of the
default pawn, I'm going to select the BP runner
care Rector. And finally, this is going to
allow us to have our own character in the
game. So if I hit the play button, there we go,
if I inject, here he is. Now we if I possess him,
we have a problem. You see, we don't see the
character, we don't see anything. And the reason
for that is we can move him if I don't know if you
notice, pay attention to where he is currently if
I possess him, and if I move like this, I'm
moving. And let's try to see where he is now.
You see, he almost fell down. So there we go.
Okay, so what do we need to do in order for this
to make this work? Well, we need to go back in our
c++ class, and over here where it says the tick.
So inside of Arctic functionality, we need
to say our temp position. So temp p o S is
going to be equal to get actor location,
again, we're getting the actor location,
our temp position that x is going to be equal
to or we're going to subtract from it 850
like this, and on the Z position, so temp position
that z is going to be equal to z position. So z
position. And last but not least, our side view
camera set world location over here, we're going
to pass the temp position, and there you go. So
what this is going to do, it's again going to
get the current actor location, the current actor
location is basically Well, the actor location,
just getting but the current location is the
location of our own actor of the character,
we are going to then change the exposition,
So subtract from it 850, and the Z position is
going to stay the one that we have over here, and
then we're going to set that position to the word
location of the camera. So Ctrl Shift B in order
for us to compile this. And by the way, I'm not
going to do that, but you're going to do it if you
want to see the outcome like if you change this
number to minus 1000 minus 100 said the Z position
over here, I don't know plus 500. Try it out see
the outcome that will be you know, that will be
our practice you will understand more so if I
hit the play button now There we go. You see here
is our character he falls down Look at that, we
but if he falls down like that, we cannot see him
anymore. So that's all there is to it. Anyways,
again, hit the play button, we can possess the
character, look at that, we can move over here, we
can move over here. That's the point you see, and
he is rotating towards the direction where we are
moving. If we move backwards, you see he rotates
to move backwards. If we move forward, he rotates
to move forward. There you go, we can press base
to jump like that. There you go. But the issue
is we only have this one platform. How are what we
need to do well, we need to create more platforms,
it's logic. So starting from the next video, we
are going to prepare everything to start creating
our level parts and then we are of course going to
start encoding all of that so that we can have our
level to play the game. If something was not clear
in regards to this video, make sure that you ask
in the comment down below and I will help you
out and I will see you guys in the next video.
Alrighty then my game dev ELS before we can
create our level we also need to create the
obstacles because they are going to be part of
the level. So over here in our c++ class, I am
going to create a new c++ class and it is going
to inherit from the actor. So one is going to be
called obstacle. So over here, I'm going to see
up the call. And of course wait for Unreal Engine
to add it into the project again, that SSD is
going to arrive on Mondays or Thursday, Tuesday,
because now it's Saturday for me recording this.
I'm going to sing to you in the meantime then
and then and then and then and then and then and
then and then and then and then and then and then
thank you very much that will be $5 extra. Now the
bad news is that we need to create another one.
So I right click over here, New c++ class, and
this time an actor again and this one is going
to be spikes. So spikes There you go, hit enter,
of course and wait for it to torture us. What else
can I say? The good thing is that we are not going
to code anything. Instead, we're just going to
use these classes so that we can, you know, do a
cast later on when we collide with these objects,
of course, from the blueprints that we will
create. So over here, if I open it, let me
just reload everything, reload again. There you
go. So we have the spikes, we have the obstacle.
But as I said, we are not going to code anything
over here. Instead, we're just going to use these
as references to create blueprints. So let's go
back in our Unreal Engine, and over here into
the blueprints, I'm going to right click a new
folder, and I'm going to call this one obstacles.
And inside of the obstacles, I'm going to
create a blueprint class one is going to
inherit from the obstacle, which is this bad
boy. And I'm going to call it BB obstacle.
Simple, very simple, right click again, blueprint
class. And over here, one is going to inherit from
the spikes. And I'm going to call it BP underscore
spikes. Simple. Double click it, open it in
our editor over here almost said Visual Studio,
but it's actually the editor again. So what are
we going to do? Well, first things first, for the
spikes, I am going to click on this BP spikes and
add a static mesh component that I'm simply going
to call spike very simple. Now for the spike
Static Mesh over here, I'm going to click on the
drop down list and filter for our quad pyramids.
I'm going to say quad pyramids, there you go,
this is the one that we want. And over here for
the materials, I am going to filter for the clay
new, and this is the one that we want. There you
go. This is pretty much it except over here, I'm
going to set it to minus 50 on the Z position,
so simple as that. And also when it comes
to the collision, we are going to do one
interesting thing. First things first, I'm going
to compile and save this and I'm going to go here
into the project settings. And I'm going to go
here into the collision for the project settings.
So it's basically this over here under engine
when you go into the project settings. Over here,
we can create our own object channels. What does
that mean? That basically means we can create our
own layers to differentiate the collision between
actors. So over here, I'm going to click on new
object channel, and the name for that one is going
to be obstacle and the obstacle is going to block.
So the obstacle is simply going to block the
player, it's basically going to be a solid body
not allowing the player to pass through. And that
is what a block is. And I'm going to click here
except next over here, I'm going to say new object
channel and this one is going to be our spike,
but the spike is going to overlap, the spike is
going to overlap so that we can overlap in the
deck collision between the spike and the player.
I'm going to click here except so now we have
the block and the overlap channels over here. What
does that mean that means now that I can go inside
of the spikes over here and scroll down over here
where it says the collision There you go, this
bad boy over here, I can zoom in for you to see
There you go. So over here the collision preset.
I'm going to set that to custom so click on the
drop down list and click here of custom from the
list. Over here we are going to have the collision
back to query only. So we are going to have query
only no physics collision because we don't
want the physics we don't want to collide as
a physics object with our pyramid or basically
the spike and over here for the object type.
Now we are going to have so let me just Compile
and Save this. So now we should see the spike and
the obstacle which is the one that we have just
created over here. If you don't see it right away,
just Compile and Save for your blueprint. And
then here from the object type where it says world
dynamic you can select this one to be spike, and
there you go. So over here I'm going to set our
spike to overlap everything except over here the
obstacle I don't want it to overlap the obstacle
and we can also set here not to overlap or simply
ignore the camera because we don't need the camera
Compile and Save that. So it is going to overlap
all of these other ones. responses such as the
pawn physics body, which basically our player
were going to set him to be upon. So this right
here will be able to overlap with the player. And
of course then we will detect collision between
them and destroy the player and all of that good
stuff. So now we can move forward to our cube
or to the obstacle which is this one and again,
from here static component we are going to filter
for our static mesh, and I'm going to call this
one cube or simply call it block obstacle There
you go. Over here for the static mesh, I am going
to filter for the cube. So simply type cube and
there you go, where is the QB QB. There you go,
here is the QB QB. And over here for the material,
I'm going to say basic shape material. This is
what I want Compile and Save that. Now I'm going
to leave at 000 for X, Y and Z and I'm not going
to touch it rotation I mean there is no point in
touching the rotation because it will still be the
same it's a cube. And going back over here again
for the collision preset instead of block all
dynamic we are going to set it to custom over here
the collision enabled will be query and physics
because again, this obstacle this block obstacle,
it is going to be a solid body and it is going to
block the player when the player collides with it,
the player will not be able to pass through it.
And over here for the object type we're going to
set that to be an obstacle and we are going to set
it to block everything except over here to spike
we don't need it to block the spike you can simply
overlap this spike, but it is going to block
everything meaning it's a solid body, I'm simply
going to compile and save that and there you go.
So this is pretty much it as a preparation when it
comes to creating our level parts. Now of course
if something was not clear, make sure that you ask
in the comment down below and starting from the
next video we are going to build our level pirates
and the level and all of the good stuff then we're
going to start spawning them and yada yada
yada. So I will see you guys in the next video
would it is game day begins here EDA has moving
forward now we are going to create our levels and
for that we are going to go inside of our c++
classes and right click and build a base level
class which is going to inherit from the actor
and I'm going to call this one so over here,
base level and hit enter to create the class
and of course, we will have to wait a moment
or two or a gazillion moments for Unreal Engine
to take mercy upon our motors mortal souls.
Until we forget SSD man the more you watch these
videos, the more ad revenue i get i guess and the
more faster I can buy that SSD. Just kidding,
but let's go over here and reload everything
there you go. Here we have our base level dot
age and here we have our base level dot cpp
so inside of our dot h The first thing here at
the top right below the includes over here I'm
going to forward the Claire so I'm going to say
class you box bone and as I said this is called
forward the coloration so that we don't have to
use the import or include Excuse me. Now going
back here at the bottom right below the public
virtual void I'm going to create protected
and I am going to create a new property. And
this your property is going to be blueprint
read and write it is also going to be
editable anywhere. So edit anywhere.
And last but not least I'm going to set it under
a category which is going to be equal to triggers
like that. What the hell is this teacher I don't
know I'm confused the I want to slap you listen,
listen, and don't slap me. Okay, so what we
have over here is blueprint read and write,
basically meaning the component that we now
declare which is going to be a you box component,
which is a pointer, so I need to add a star over
here. And I need to call this or I don't need but
I'm going to call it a trigger, which means that
this component trigger can be read and written, we
can edit it and we can get a value of it inside of
the blueprint edit anywhere means we can edit it
inside of the Blueprint Editor on the side in the
details tab. And the category triggers basically
when we search for this component in the blueprint
code, we will find it under the triggers category.
So we can also call it my triggers you can call
it like that and we will see that when we search
for it. So what I'm going to do is copy this and
paste it down below because we are going to have
the same signature, but this time we're not going
to call this one trigger but I'm going to call it
spawn location like that. And last but not least,
we're going to have to public function so public
like that. And what's gonna happen here
these functions are going to return a u box
component which is a pointer so this one is
going to be get trigger which is going to get
our trigger not Teague. It's a trigger,
and another one for you box component.
And it is a pointer. So over here, I'm going to
say get spawn location like that. And there we go.
Now don't worry if this is still white text,
you know takes unreal lunger engine for this to
compile. While we're waiting for that SSD, you get
my point I'm going to right click on this bad boy
quick actions and refactoring, I'm going to create
a declaration for it over here, do the same thing,
quick actions, refactoring, create a declaration
for it. And of course, I don't know what to say I
mean, you see, you see the issues we all have. So
inside of our CPP is where we are going to include
same as what we do with our players. So include,
and I'm going to include components, backslash box
component dot h, it's that age, there you go. And
inside of our Begin Play, I am first going to test
if the trigger, if it's not equal to null
PTR, meaning null pointer, then I'm going to
say trigger. And from here, I'm going to say be
hidden in game is going to be equal to true and
not allow that trigger to be you know, visible
in the game live, just compile all of this,
so that we make sure that nothing is wrong, and
that everything should be working because it's
not giving me out to complete the argument, the
anything you see build succeeded, we're good to
go. But you know, it takes Unreal Engine, I will
probably have to restart or close my Visual Studio
and open it for this to work. I don't know, do
not ask me over here right now going to return
a null pointer, instead, I'm going to return a
trigger. And over here, I'm not going to return an
old pointer, instead, I'm going to return a spawn
location. That's all there is to it. And again,
make sure that you compile or build this. So it's
Ctrl, Shift B to build this code. And voila, there
you go. Of course, another way to build this code
is to go here and simply Click Compile does the
same exact thing. But I am not going to do that.
Otherwise, we will wait a lot. So let's go over
here inside of our blueprints, and right click
and create a new folder, and this one is going
to be our levels inside of the levels folder, I'm
going to right click and create a blueprint class
and inherit from the base level, there you go and
select I'm going to call this on BP level one,
of course, we're going to have level two up to
level 10. And what's going to happen in this one,
I'm going to open it and I'm going to create a
few levels. And then I'm going to leave up to
you to create the other levels because you know,
this process can be a little bit tedious, it takes
a little bit of time and all of the good stuff,
the first thing that I'm going to do over here,
in side of the inside of the VP level,
I'm going to go and add a few components,
the first few are going to be a static mesh, one
is going to be a floor. And another one, I'm going
to duplicate this bad boy, so copy and paste then
instead of floor, I'm going to call this one cube,
there you go. And also I'm going to have to box
trigger. So box collision, that is one I am going
to call and this is not going to be a child of the
cube. So I'm going to call this one trigger box,
copy and paste it and this one, I am going to
call it spawn location box. Let me just Compile
and Save that. And let me just add everything
that I need. And we are going to code or
actually before that in the Event Graph. What I'm
going to do is remove all of this. And over here
we have in the Event Begin Play, I'm going to set
the spawn location. So I'm going to right click
over here and I'm going to say set spawn location.
And notice it's under my triggers. Look at that,
you see this over here. Look at my triggers.
It's basically what we did in our code. So
if I go back over here, where we have declared
these triggers, look at that. So my triggers,
this is that category. So now we can find them
under this category inside of our blueprints
when we want to code. So I'm going to right
click and I'm going to say set spawn location
and the spawn location again, make sure
that it is under my trigger. So set spawn
location, here it is under my triggers,
and execution flow is going to go over here
and I'm going to set that or the spawn
location box is going to be the spawn location.
Next from there, I'm going to say set trigger,
and it's this one over here under my triggers.
So the execution flow is going to continue over
here and then I'm going to take the trigger box
and plug it in over here and let me just Compile
and Save that. What this is going to do is going
to set the spawn location from our code to this
one over here. So we have have, you know connected
these two, meaning that now this is a reference to
this over here, same thing that we did over here,
make sure that you Compile and Save that. So
now going inside of our viewport, and here
is my floor, what am I going to do to the floor?
Well, I'm not going to do anything to the floor,
because you know, I'm a good boy, I'm not going
to do anything. Instead, what I'm going to do
is go over here for the static mesh and filter
for the cube. And there you go, here is our cube
for the material, we are going to say basic shape
material, voila, that's all there is to it. And I
am going to change the scale of it. So the scale x
is going to be 10. The scale y is going to be one
and R, let me just go over here, I have locked
the icon. So I don't want to lock anything.
But over here, scale, x is going to be 10, y is
one and 0.5. So this is going to be this is going
to be our floor. Next we're going to have a cube.
So over here, taking the cube. And again, adding
a cube to it. And over here basic shape, basic
shape material, there you go. Now for this cube,
I'm going to set it and 90 for the Z position and
leave it like that, that's all there is to it,
the trigger box, I'm going to take it and for the
trigger box, I'm going to set that location 380
The location was going to be stay or
stay at zero and the location z 250.
And I am also going to set the Z scale to 10.
Over here for the trigger box, the trigger box
is basically going to be the trigger that when
we pass through it then we are going to detect
collision and then we are going to spawn a new
level. So this is what we are going to do with the
trigger box. So when the player passes here and
he touches that collision, then we are going to
then we are going to detect that and we are going
to spawn new level and over here just make sure
that it is overlap all dynamic. So the collision
preset is set to that. Next we have the spawn
location and the spawn location. What am I going
to do with it is simply I am going to reposition
it. So I'm going to position it at 1,000th. And
that's all there is to it. So the spawn location,
we are going to use its position to position
the next level. So when we spawn a new level,
it is going to start positioning from here. And
basically it's going to form a new level like
that. Simple, that's all what we are going to
do with the spawn or with the spawn location.
So this is our level one and just make
sure that you Compile and Save that. If
I go over here inside of the gameplay, I'm going
to right click and create a new blueprint class.
And now you're going to assume that again, I'm
going to use the base level but this time No,
instead I'm going to use level one. And
every next level that I create is going to be
a child of level one. So BP level one, I'm going
to select that, and this one's going to be BP
level two, there you go. And I'm simply going to
open it, it already has all of these components
set up in the Event Graph, it is going to call
the parents Begin Play which is going to do
all of this, it's going to prepare everything,
we don't have to do it again for this blueprint.
Very clever I know. And that's all there is
to it. Of course now we're simply going to
add new things to it. And that would be it,
for example, the cube that we have over here,
I'm going to reposition and so the exposition is
going to be minus 330, the Y is going to stay the
same and the Z is going to stay the same. But I'm
also going to add new boxes. So I'm going to copy
this cube and paste it and I'm going to call this
one cube two. And for this cube two, I am going to
reposition it. So x is going to be 190 y zero z
130. And I am going to set the Z scale at three
for the Z scale. Simple as that and copy this
one copy and paste now we have the cube three,
and for the cube three, the position x is minus
70, the position y 01 180 for the Z and set the
Z scale 2.3 and Wallah, Compile and Save
that. So this is our level two blueprint.
Simple, very, very simple going
back over here, right clicking,
and again blueprint class. Again, inheriting
from level one, there we go. Not level two,
but level one, and this one is going to be BP
level three. Again, we have everything prepared we
we have our base queue, we have everything here
prepared in the Event Graph. We don't have to do
anything, but we are going to change or reposition
this cube. So again, minus 330 For the x, y,
I'm not going to touch in z, I'm not going
to touch so it's going to stay as is. But now
I'm going to copy this cube and rename it to cube
two. And this cube two is going to be repositioned
at 70 for the x, y 04 20 on the z axis,
and over here, I'm going to say three scale
for the Z Compile and Save that. Moving forward,
we are going to have another level. So blueprint
class over here, inherit from the level. So
inherit from our level one, select BB, level four,
double click it and open it over here in Visual
Studio. And again, simply repositioning things
so cube over here is going to be repositioned
x is minus 303 30, excuse me, 174 the z axis,
then I'm going to copy this cube and rename it
to cube two. For our cube do, I am going to set
the position 160 on the x y zero 2020, or two to
zero for the Z and resize the Z scale to four.
Last but not least, we have another cube, so copy
and paste, and this one is going to be at the 10
for the X 370 on the Z and the scale, Z is going
to stay one, but the scale x is going to be two
and Compile and Save that this is our level
for moving forward, I'm going to right click,
and again inherit from level one. There you go.
And this one's going to be our BP level five. And
now we're going to add some spikes in here. And
this is the last level that I'm going to create
the next levels are on you. So over here for the
cube, I'm going to set the x at minus 30 and the Z
390. And I am going to set the x scale
to three the Z scale 2.3 There you go.
And last but not least, we are going to attach
something or we are going to attach a spike.
And I am going to do the following. So here
I'm going to click on Add Component selecting
the BP level and I'm going to filter for child
actor. And this one is going to be our spike.
There you go. I'm going to call this a spike
too. But of course we're going to have spike
one as well. So copy this one. And so what we
are going to do for our spike to is over here
you see the child actor component. From here,
we can select the blueprint, we can click here,
and I can filter for spikes. There you go.
And let me just remove this one I'm going
to duplicate this one after. So for this one, I'm
going to set the X to two to zero and the Z is 40
There you go. But I am going to move it a
little bit upwards so something like this.
There you go here on this position grid snap
Val and we decided to one so I can snap it a
little bit better, while odd There you go. And I'm
simply going to copy this and paste it and this
one's going to be our spike one and simply move it
over here. Basically the position x is minus 260
and there you go Compile and Save that so this is
the last level I'm going to create I'm going to
cut out the video right now and create the other
levels and go back and show you the levels that I
have created but you have plenty of info for you
to create your own levels. A quick note you don't
have to create the same levels as I did you can
create you can create levels on your own which is
a good practice and I encourage that every single
time. So again for this spikes when we you know
touch them we are going to die but we will see
that later on. Do not worry about that right now.
And basically that's it every single level that
you create is going to inherit from level one.
I'm going to cut out the video right now and
I'm going to continue just remember when you
add spikes you're going to add them as child actor
components. So from here you're going to filter
for the child actor when you select the child
actor over here we're going to select the spikes
for that child actor. And that would be it. That
will be basically it. So I don't have any the NX
anything nx I don't have anything else clever
to say I don't know how to talk I will see in
a few when I create the other level parts and
I am back Did you miss me because it took me a
while to create all this of course for you it was
a few moments but you know if you didn't miss me
then you can watch this video anymore. I'm just
getting anyways here we have the level 6789 and
10 so this is my level six as you can see you can
also download the complete project I have provided
that under the you know importing or creating the
project video you can you know download the assets
or basically the complete project as well and see
that on your own or you can create your own levels
which I highly encourage you to do but basically
this is my life. Six as you can see so we have
a cube here and two spikes Next we have the level
seven which is very simple as you can see I'm not
even moving the collision box or the trigger box
and the spawn position they're staying at the same
spot where they are in level one and I'm just you
know moving the cube resizing it adding here child
actors which are the spikes over here I have the
level eight as you can see this is my level 8123
There you go till three boxes or T three cubes
that is level nine There you go. We have a spike
in this weird thing over here the L shape if your
name is Lauren, then you know this is for you,
Lauren, and over here we have the level 10
There you go. And that's all there is to it
compile and safe. I cannot say anything else
or I don't have anything else clever to say.
Except if something is not clear. Make sure
that you ask in the comment down below.
And yeah, I will see you in the next video
you know, where else can I see you, you know,
I don't live where you live, I don't know you
in person. So I cannot see you, you know in your
home. I can see in the next video. So again, if
something's not clear, as gone below, I'll see you
in next video. Alrighty, then my game dev elf. So
let's go here in the c++ class, I'm going to right
click and create a new c++ class inherit from the
actor and this one is going to be my spawn level.
So spawn level level spawner, however you want
to name it, I do not care. You can name it car,
you can name it, same name as your grandma, that
is up to you, I cannot control you. Okay, I named
it spawn level. And this is going to be the class
that is going to allow us to spawn all of these
levels. But before we actually can do that, we
of course need to add a few things inside of that
class. But first things first, you know, the SSD
drive is still not there. I think I will finish
this recording today, which is Saturday for me, I
don't know which day is for you. And there we go.
Some info that we don't need. So here we have
the spawn level CPP and spawn level dot h. So
what's going to happen in the spawn level dot h,
first things first here above below the includes,
I am going to add my a base level class, because
we are going to have levels that we are going to
put inside of this inside of the spawn level. So
over here, I am going to create another public
like this. I know it's right below the public.
This is how I differentiate my own variables,
I like to group them and that's all there is to
it. So over here, I'm going to create a u function
like that. And this is going to be my void spawn
level, which is going to take a Boolean is first
meaning is this the first level that we are
going to spawn, we're also going to have
our own on begin overlap. So I'm going to go
here inside of our player character and simply
grab it from here so that I don't have to write
all of these parameters and all of that stuff,
you get the point it can be a little bit
tedious, it can be a little bit you know,
whatever. So there you go. So just go from the
player and grab it copy and paste it is the
same signature, the same name and everything.
Next over here we are going to have protected.
And for the protected, we are going to first
have a player who is upon and it's a pointer
and I'm going to call him player, we are going
to get a reference to the player. Next over here,
I'm going to create a new property,
your property which is going to be added
anywhere. So we will be able to edit it from
the blueprint itself and is going to be a T
sub class of a base level and is going to
be our level one. And this is the reason why
I have imported this over here. So don't worry
if you don't have those autocompletes I mean,
I don't have them. As you can see, the reason for
that is simple because Unreal Engine is slow. And
you know, reading all of this and the SSD drive is
still not here. So over here we have the level two
and we have the level three, come on level four,
come on level five, you can see you know, some
not everything about the game that is, you know,
fun and all of that stuff. Some things are a
little bit tedious for you and me to do but hey,
you sign up for this, I did not you know, I didn't
threaten you or whatever didn't force you. So
this is all on you. Next year we're going to
have a T array or simply an array of a base
level who are pointers, and there's going to
be my level list. And last but not least,
we are going to have also public variables
one is going to be a random level because we are
going to randomize the spawning of the level.
We are also going to have an F vector which is
going to be our spawn location for the level
and I'm going to call here f vector simply
like that. We're also going to have the F
rotate tour and this is going to be our spawn
rotation again f rotate or simply declare it
over here and our f x spawn parameters which is
going to be our spawn info was going to be equal
to again simply copy this over here so that I
can declare it because these are the variables
that we are going to use over and over. And Ctrl
Shift to build this bad boy because you know,
I need to build it okay. And yeah, that will
be its Let us wait for it a moment or two.
And there you go. We have something over here I
believe function public static void. Expect struck
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. I didn't actually,
you know, declared these do so right click
quick actions and refactorings create the
definition. Simple. Right click Actions and
refactoring create the definition. Again, very
simple, but yet, you know, people are forgettable,
they tend to forget things as you just saw that.
I cannot wait for that SSD to arrive, man. It's
like, you know, I'm waiting for a new life, like
I die that I'm not waiting to live again. So yep,
I'm going to sing to you. Let me take my
Oh, Colin 18 Union union union union union.
I'm kidding, I don't have a ukulele. I don't
know what that is. I just heard that word.
And I told you that Okay, so over here, let me
just now compile this. And you see only now we
see you know, different colors of everything that
we have declared and stuff like that. But now the
you know, completion or the build has succeeded.
There you go. So now inside of the spawn level,
we are going to include or add our includes. So
we are going to have over here include base level
that age, though that is one of the includes the
next include is going to be our engine dot age. So
we're going to use the whole engine. And the
last include is going to be our components,
box component dot h like that. There you go. And
I don't know why it's giving me here a red because
you know, it's included the same thing. So what do
we need to create here, inside of our spawn level,
is where the main thing the main magic is going
to happen. So over here, what I'm going to do, I'm
going to say spawn location is going to be equal
to f vector. And over here, I'm going to say 0.0,
f 1000 for the y and 0.0, F for the z, y 1000 will
because 1000 units is or 1000 centimeters is how
large the level is because we you know, set the
level to be 10 scale on the x axis, I believe,
I think was x axis I cannot remember. But anyways,
it's 1000 units, which means that when we have one
level over here, if we want to place another
level over here, that's 1000 units, that's all
there is to it. Next we have the spawn rotation,
which is going to be equal to f rotate or, and
it is going to be zero here, 90 here and zero
here, so on the Y where simply and wrote a shit
like that. So 90 on the y and there you
go. What I'm also going to check over here,
or perform a check if this is not the first
time we're spawning, so if not his first
which is basically the parameter that we are
going to pass here when we spawn the first
level we are going to say this is true. But for
all other levels, this is not going to be true.
So if it's not the first level, then I'm going
to say here a base level which is a pointer, last
level I'm going to get the last level I'm going to
say level list. And that last and this is from the
array of the level list where I'm going to get the
last level and the reason for that is because now
I'm going to say spawn location. So spawn location
is going to be equal to last level. And from here
I'm going to say get spawn location. And from
there I'm going to get the component transform
component transform, and from there I'm going to
say dot get translation There you go. And if I
can finish the statement, if I hover over it says
returns the translation of the component basically
it will return the position of our spawn location
and notice here I'm using get spawn location if
you remember in our base level over here, we're
getting the spawn location by returning it Look at
that get spawn location, we're returning the spawn
location and if you double remember inside of the
blueprint for that so if I go over here inside
of the blueprints and the level and over here,
we are setting the spawn location to be equal to
this one which is this bad boy over here and this
is that spawn location. So we are going to get
that value that reference here. And from there,
we're going to know where is the last position of
the last level. So next over here, I'm going to
randomize this, I'm going to say a random level is
going to be equal to f math, call on call on. And
I'm going to use a Rand range between one and
10, which is going to return numbers between one
and 10, including both of these. And then I'm
going to say a base level, which is a pointer,
new level, by default is going to be
equal to null PTR. So null pointer,
but now I am going to test for the random level.
So if our random level is equal to one like that,
then I'm going to say new level, which is
the one that we have just created over here,
that is going to be equal to get the world. And
from the world, I'm going to spawn an actor,
which is a type of base level. So this is
going to be the actor that we're going to spawn
and we're going to spawn the level one actor at
the spawn location, using the spawn rotation,
throwing bars at the Mars and and over here,
we're going to use the spawn info. So spawn
in felt like that. There you go. And simply
now I can copy this, and I can say, Here else,
and paste this over here. If the random level is
equal to do then over here, I'm simply going to
spawn level two, that's all there is to it, we
need to read and we need to need to, why am I
saying limini, we need to repeat this process.
So again, this one is three. Now over here,
we need to spawn the level three, going back over
here, as I said, Sometimes things can get tedious
over here, random level four, over here and the
level four, of course, we can do this, you know,
I mean, we need to do it, I don't know what I
wanted to say, anyways, six now. And over here,
there you go six, over here, now
Come on, are going to have 7789
and 10. And we're done. So don't Don't cry, don't
be a cry, baby, and all of that stuff, be patient.
Imagine how I felt when I
created all of this, you know,
so yeah, there we go. The last one is here. And
finally, we are done. So down over here, spawning
the 10 over here. So based on the as you can see,
based on the random level that we have over here,
then we are going to, as I said, this is going
to return either one or 10 or numbers in between.
So based on those numbers, then we are going
to set the new level which is currently at
null pointer to be equal to one of these levels.
If it's one, then level one than dude and three,
you get the point. But if something is not clear,
make sure you ask in the comment down below.
Over here what I'm going to do if we have a
new level, we need to perform this test because
otherwise, if this gets to an old pointer, but of
course there is no chance that this will get to
an old pointer because over here where you know
the randomized numbers are from one to 10. And
we're testing for all of them. But if we have
a level, then we are going to say if new level
and from here I'm going to get the trigger. So I'm
going to get the trigger from the new level again,
what is this new trigger if or getting the trigger
if you remember from the base level over here,
we are getting the trigger we're returning that
the trigger is again, the huge box over here,
this is the trigger where the player needs to
pass by so if the player passes by this trigger,
then we are going to spawn new levels. Simple as
that very, very simple. So if I go back over here,
so if we can get the trigger, then we're
going to say new level and from there gets
the trigger. And from the trigger we are going
to say on component begin overlap dot now we are
going to add the dynamic which is basically we're
going to assign a function that will be executed
when we begin that overlap. So I'm going to say
this, and from here I am simply going to copy this
and I'm going to say and and paste this over
here. So essentially, when we collide with the
trigger of the level, the one that I showed you
a moment ago, we are going to call the on overlap
begin from over here from the spawn level. And
over here, what we are going to do is we're going
to call spawn level, passing false to spawn a new
level, simple as that. So it's going to pass or
go through all of this over here same as what we
did right now go through it, and then it is simply
going to spawn a new level And basically
that's all there is to it, that's pretty much
all there is to it, nothing, you know more.
And over here, inside of our on Begin Play, we
need to spawn the level. So spawn level and over
here I'm going to say true. But I'm going to copy
this because the first one is going to be true
and the next three are going to be false over here
false. Let me just copy paste, copy, paste,
let me just compile this and make sure that
we don't have any problems and issues because you
know, this is coding I am you know, I cannot code
according to some of the comments. So it can
happen that I miss something and all of that good
stuff. So essentially over here in the and while
this is compiling, I'm going to try and explain
what is going on. So over here, we have created
a spawn level function that is going to spawn
new levels, we have the spawn location, we have
the spawn rotation. And over here if it's not
the first, because when we spawn, the first one,
we're going to say it's true, but for all others
is going to be false. So if it's not the first
level platform that is going to be spawned,
then we're going to get the last level inside of
our level array. And we of course need to add,
which is one thing that we need to do at the end,
so we need to add our level to the level list. So
we're going to get the last level from the level
list and then we're going to get its location of
the spawn location which is a component that we
added. So we're going to get its location and
know from where we should spawn the next level.
Over here we're going to randomize the value so
from one to 10, and if that random value is equal
to one, we're going to spawn level one if it's to
level two, and so on up to level 10 over here as
I said, I did forget so if we have new level after
that, so we are going to attach a dynamic and what
the hell is this again when I save the seed saving
because it's processing everything gold this year.
So again, if we have a new level and we do all of
this over here so we get the trigger from the
level we attach the on component begin overlap
we add that to the dynamic spawn level and all of
that good stuff. Then over here I'm going to say
level list dot add and I am going to an over here
it's actually level list like that and capital A
and I'm going to add the new level so new level
there you go. But I am not going to allow to have
more than five elements inside of the level list.
So over here I'm going to test if our level list
dot num so if the length or how many elements we
have in that level list is more than five then
from there I'm going to say level list dot remove
add and I'm going to remove the last element
inside of that level list. Now the bad
news is that this still did not compile
and the even more worse news is that we need to
compile it again. So I'm probably going to cut
out the video right here until the SSD drive
arrives and I'm going to continue from the you
know when this compiles but again here at the end
what we did is we added the new level to the level
list so that we you know next time when we try
to get the last level we will actually have it
so we will not have an empty list but we
will have a level inside of that list and
we are checking if the elements or how many
elements are inside of that level list. If that
number exceeds five then we're going to remove
the element that's at index zero meaning the
first level that's there so that's all there is to
it and I will see you in a few when this compiles
and I am back we have a problem over here that
is the reason why this was yelling at me so
here spawn rotation I do need to declare this as
spawn rotation and all here for every single level
I need to add that to spawn rotation so spawn
location here spawn rotation, there you go.
Here it's bond rotation, rotation rotation,
stupid misspelling, I really cannot wait for that
SSD drive to arrive you know I'm saying this
SSD drive over and over again in hopes that
some of you guys will send it to me but you know
apparently nothing will come out of it so I need
to rebuild this again but this time I think it
will be faster because it rebuild it at once
so it you know went through that whole process and
you know, it now knows it can go faster because we
for sure waited a little bit. Well, a little
more bit for all of this to reload. Anyways,
come on. Let us wait and now there we go
build has succeeded. Finally, finally,
finally. If something was not clear in regards
to this one and I've explained it two times,
make sure that you ask in the comment down below
because now we need to move on and go here inside
of our blueprints and right click and create
our levels bahner who who is going to you know,
inherit from the level or spawn level Sue spawn
level there you go. From here I need to say BP
spawn level and go inside and attach all of these
levels so we need to attach all of these levels so
from here, we need to take level one, then level
two, then here we have level three and all of that
good stuff so the tedious part that nobody likes
to do but everybody likes to play the game. So
eight and nine and last but not least here is
our level 10 and we need to Compile and Save that
so now I can go here in the gameplay and
I can simply put my level spawn or I can
put him here 000 It does not matter what
matters is if I hit the play button that
he will spawn the levels and indeed he did
there you go look at that all of the levels
I can possess the character and now I can run and
every single time we you know pass the trigger,
we will spawn new levels as you can see over
here we have infinite number of levels and every
single time you see they're differentiated Look
at that, then I can run and all of the good stuff
and yada yada yada you get the point. So there you
go. As you can see we can run infinite the leap so
the last step is to add our wall that is chasing
us that is going to kill us that we need to and
there we go for whatever reason why these levels
huh this was for the I need to redo the level or
recheck this level that has these two I
probably need to reposition the oh actually no,
I don't need to reposition but I need to make
that trigger a little bit larger because we
jumped over it and that is the reason why that is
the reason why we did not have new levels so we
need to make sure that the trigger is a little
bit larger because again here is the level you
see we just need to make sure that the trigger is
larger on every single level that is so make sure
and since we are inheriting from the level one
we can I believe go simply over here inside of
the levels level one there we go and make this
over here the trigger box a little bit larger
so I don't know let's say 20 something like
that so it will not allow it and we can move it
there you go so now the player has no chance
five to five is going to be the position for it
unit 530530 and Compile and Save that and I
believe it will change it for every single level
yes it will there you go it will change it
for every single level. So as I said now the
player will not be able to jump over it and it
will not give us the problem that we just had
of not having the level so now even if I go from
here and I tried to jump way over here I'm still
going to create new levels there you go. So if
something was not clear in regards to this video
just ask I will not answer and just kidding I
will answer and help you out. And that will be
it for this video I will see you guys in the next
one we're going to create our wall that is going
to start to chase us and all of that stuff and
then we are going to wrap up our game see it then
All righty then my game Deaf gangsta Roni owes
Let us wrap up our game so going here inside of
our c++ classes are going to create a new c++
class but this one is going to inherit from
the spike so I'm going to click here show all
classes and filter for our spikes it's it's not
spike spike just it spikes there you go and this
one is going to be our wall spike There you go.
And what's gonna happen inside of this class is
I am not going to do basically anything in the
dot h file but of course we need to you know
go through the painful process of all of this
man send me that SSD What else can I say? I'm
waiting for it just kidding in a few days it will
come to in the next tutorial we'll be ready and
this is going to be fast as as as a as something
that is fast, I don't know a squirrel. So in
the wall, let's go over here reload everything
first wall spike that age, I'm not going to do
anything but in the dot cpp file we are going to
do something. So over here basically in the dot
h file we are going to have all of the you know
basic so we have the generated body we are going
to have a public over here we're going to have a
wall spike which is our constructor in the
protected so protect that. We are going to
have our virtual void. So virtual void Begin
Play because we want to override it. So override
in our public, we're going to have our. So
from here, it's going to be virtual, void,
tick, and it's going to be float Delta
time. And over here, override, there you go.
Because now in the dot cpp file, we are
going to implement all of that. So over here,
we are going to say a wool spike
colon colon, and is going to be our
a will spike basically the constructor. And
over here, we're going to have our primary
actor tick that B can ever tick is equal
to true. So we're going to enable that
also over here in our void, a wall spike
call on call on is going to be our begin.
So it's begin blay. What's going to happen over
here, first, you're going to call the super,
which is the superclass and call the Begin Play
from there. So begin, play. There you go, actually
begin play like this. And then from here, what
I'm going to do is it's not being it's begin play
like that Begin Play, I'm going to say this,
and I'm going to get the root component from
our blueprint, and I'm going to say component,
so component velocity, and we just said that F
vector, zero for the X 25 for the y and zero for
the Z. So this is the velocity, or basically the
speed of our of the actor. And next, I'm going to
say Boyd, a wall spike with double or capital W
spike, call on call on tick. And over here,
we're going to have the Delta time, like that.
So what's going to happen over here again,
first, I'm going to call the super dick. So
super dick, which is going to take the Delta
time and I know you're expecting me to do some
jokes, oh, you're tick. Look, I'm not Danny,
I'm not trying to be Danny, I don't care,
you know, I'm not going to do the tick joke and
whatnot, said actor location. And from here,
I'm going to get the actor location, which is
the current location of this actor, and I'm
going to add to it on F a vector. And inside of
this F vector, I'm going to say zero for decks
350 for the Y, multiplied with Delta time, delta
time. So it's Delta time, there you go, and zero
for the Z. And over here, I'm going to say true.
And that's all there is to it. So let me just
compile this and we can make sure that everything
is okay, we don't have any issues. Essentially,
what we did over here is inside of our Begin Play,
there we go succeeded we are good. In on Begin
Play, we set the component velocity of the root
component to be 25 on the y and then over here,
inside of the tick, we are moving the actor by
using its current location and adding to it only
the Y here because x and z are zero, that means
they will not move and we're adding to it's 350
multiply with Delta time, of course, you can set a
public variable speed or something like that. That
is, you know, up to you if you want to do that.
I'm not going to do it. But yeah, there we go. So
let's go inside of the editor. And inside of the
blueprints that I'm going to go in the obstacles
and right click and create a wall obstacle. So I'm
going to say well spike, because it is going to
inherit from the wall spike BP will spike and we
need to edit this, we need to edit it to look like
a wall. So over here, I am going to filter for the
static mesh that I'm going to call walls simply
over here for the Static Mesh which is going
to be our cube I'm going to say cube like that.
There you go. And here basic shape material
Wallah. I'm going to change you know the scale so
the y and the Z scale are going to be 10. This is
it. Over here for our presets you see it's set to
block all dynamic instead over here and we'd say
no collision. Now the reason for that is because
I'm going to detect collision with a box
Collider. So I'm going to here go here and
I'm going to say bar collision. And simply
call it box you can call it box or however,
and for this one, I am going to set the x scale at
three y scale is going to be 20 and the Z scale is
going to be 20. And with this one I want to detect
collision with our player. And in order for me
to do that, I'm going to scroll down over
here where it says for the collision presets
and I am going To set this one to the custom
collision, over here, I'm going to say query only
no physics collision. So basically no physics
collision over here for the world dynamic,
I'm actually going to set this to spike, because
the spike will be able to collide with the player,
Compile and Save that now in order for us or for
this to work, we are going to go in our player,
which is this one, let me just close these
levels. So closing, all of the levels Come on,
there you go. For the player, I'm going to
select his capsule component and scroll down
over here for the collision preset, it is set
to be a custom one end it is said to be upon. So
this is what we need to do, we'll set it to be a
custom one, set it to be upon make sure that it is
overlapping the spike, because that is what
we need. So we need it to overlap the spike.
Now what we need to do is go over here inside of
our game, and we are going to add our wolf spike,
here he is, and let me just reposition him.
So the exposition is going to be minus 30,
the Y is going to be minus 830 and the Z
it's 455. And of course, I'm also going to
rotate it 90 degrees on the so 90 degrees on the
z axis. If I hit the play button now There we go,
you see, it is going it is trying to search for
us or actually trying to get us if it catches
us looking now is simply going to pass through
us we're not detecting collision in the code.
This is why we don't see anything. So we need
to detect collision in the code for anything
to happen. But the point that I wanted to show
you is that it is not the tech thing. It is not
a solid object, it simply passes through. So how
can we detect collision with the player I don't
want to leave that in the next video. Instead,
I'm going to do it right now I can leave it
in the next video, but I'm going to do it right
now. So going back over here inside of our runner
character CPP at the top here, so inside of Begin
Play after or before we set can move to be true,
we need to get the capsule component so we need to
say get capsule component which is a component the
capsule component of the player that we have
just edited. You know the one that I said it,
it needs to be upon. So from there, I'm going to
see on component begin overlap dot and I would say
add dynamic. And over here we're going to add this
and I'm simply going to go down and copy the name
over here so that we don't have to, you know,
type it out. So and and that there you go. So
this is going to take that capital component from
the player, which is you know, in the blueprints,
so taking that capsule component, then it is going
to attach to it are on begin overlap or on overlap
begin. So essentially what's going to happen
inside of this one is that we are going to detect
if we have collided with a spike or a wall spike.
So over here I'm going to say if the other actor
is not equal to no PTR. So it's PTR, not TPR.
It's PTR other actor is basically the actor,
the other one that we have collided with inside
of our game. So if it's not equal to no we have
collided with some of the actors then we're
going to say a spike like that, or spikes which
is a pointer. And I'm going to say here walls
spikes There you go, or wall spike and that
is going to be equal to I'm going to cast that
to a wall spike like that and I'm casting the
other actor. Now we don't have the completion
or anything because we do need to go here on top
and right here we need to include a few things so
we need to say include our spikes dot h file, we
also need to include our wall spike dot h file and
last but not least, we need to include the engine.
So it's engine dot h because we are going to
restart the game when the player dies in order
for us to do that. Then we need to use the
engine and there we go over here our spikes
wall spike we're going to do that or try to cast
that next I'm going to say a spikes and over here
because it's a pointer spike and I'm going
to cast it into a spike like that then
I'm casting again the other actor same as
what I did be for naturally here it spikes
not spike. So essentially if we collide
with either the wall so if wall spike or
we have the spike. So if we collide with any of
these meaning they are not not so essentially
over here what we are trying to do we are casting
the other actor to the wall spike And other actor
to the spike spike basically. So below over here
we're testing if we have a wool spike, or if we
have a spike, meaning they're not equal to null,
that means we collided with one of the two, that
means game over. So now I'm going to say get mash,
which is going to get the mesh of our character,
and then I'm going to deactivate that mesh, I'm
also going to say get mesh. And from here, I
am going to say set visibility for that mesh to be
false so that we don't see it anymore in the game
can move is now equal to false, we cannot move
anymore. And next we are going to reload the level
after two seconds. And for that we need to create
f timer handle I'm going to say on used so on used
handle like that. And I'm going to say
get world timer manager. And from there,
I'm going to say set timer. And I'm going to pass
the unused handle so on use the handle into this
and then I am going to pass this function which
is our runner re start level. So over here and
passing the restart level passing over here too,
because after two seconds, I want that to restart
and over here I'm going to say false because I
don't want this to loop and be an infinite loop
and spawn over and over and over again. The last
step over here is inside of our restart level,
we simply need to call you gameplay statics. So
check out the statics and over here, open level.
And simply we can pass the name of the level
or we can do this, I can pass this and I can
say the name of the level instead of passing the
name. I can say here with a star get world like
that. And over here get the name there you go.
And voila, this world is going to get the name
of the current level that we are in and it
is going to paste it over here I'm going
to compile this and while I'm compiling
I am going to explain what is going on
inside of here. I don't think there is nothing
to explain because we already explained that
inside of our runner character we attached here
the on begin overlap for the capsule collider.
That's everything what we did. And over here
we're testing if we have the other actor,
meaning we have collided with something so the
other actor is not equal to null and there we go,
the build has succeeded. So our game is done.
And over here we have the other act and we
have collided with something. So try to cast
that other actor into a wall spike or a spike,
basically meaning try to test if the other actor
is the wolf spike or if the other actor is the
spike. Is that true is that the case basically
this is what we're asking. And if we have
either of these so if we have a wolf spike or
we have a spike meaning they're not equal to No,
we are going to get the mesh and the activated
we're also going to set the visibility of the mesh
to false so that we don't see it anymore we cannot
move inside of our game so that when we press the
buttons we will not be able to move because
over here if you remember only if we can move
now we're going to have the move add the movement
to the player and then over here we're going to
restart the level this is the signature how you
restart the level so we need to pass this timer
handle even though we're not using it passing
this referring to this class this is the function
I want to be called after two seconds and no I
don't want it to loop I don't want it to repeat
over and over again and over here simply calling
gameplay statics open level passing the level name
to reload the level and that's pretty much it we
are done so if I hit the play button right now
when we you know collide with the spikes or this
wall so now when the wall touches me there we
go the character has disappeared now we restarted
the level and if I collide with one of the spikes
So come on let's try here is one of the spikes
there you go bam. I've also died and there we go.
This is our game Let's try it out again
again let's run Let's run anyways you get
the point. Congratulations for making it till
the end of this game. If you liked this video,
hit the like button and subscribe to the channel
all the good stuff because it will help me out
you know I'm trying to spread the word about
my wisdom and just kidding but anyways, you get
the point. So I don't have anything else to say.
If you like this, you have more tutorials in my
game development Academy. Thank you for watching
again and I will see you guys in the next video.